Канцлерка Німеччини Анґела Меркель -
одна з найвпливовіших жінок Європи і світу, утім далеко не найзаможніша.
утім далеко не найзаможніша.
Скільки вона заробляє, де живе і де любить відпочивати?
Заробітна плата німецької канцлерки
у відкритому доступі
і складає майже 19 тисяч євро
на місяць у 2018 році.
А оскільки Анґела Меркель - ще й депутатка Бундестагу,
то отримує половину платні члена німецького парламенту -
близько 4,5 тисяч євро.
Загалом минулоріч набігло майже
300 тисяч євро брутто.
Це одна з найбільших зарплат серед світових лідерів.
За даними гамбурзького інституту Statista,
значно більше за Меркель у 2016 році заробили
лише президент США Дональд Трамп та
прем’єр-міністр Сінгапура Лі Сяньлун.
Щоправда, в Німеччині доходи Меркель
не вважаються захмарними.
Приміром, депутат Бундестагу Ганс Міхельбах
у 2017 році із додаткових джерел
цілком легально заробив понад 250 тисяч євро.
А, наприклад, керівник регіонального
громадсько-правового мовника WDR
заробляє на рік на своїй посаді майже 400 тисяч євро.
Анґела Меркель живе у престижному районі у центрі Берліна.
Будинок багатоквартирний, помешкання
канцлерки - на четвертому поверсі.
Її попередник - Ґергард Шредер
жив у службовій квартирі в будівлі
відомства федерального канцлера.
Натомість Анґела Меркель та її чоловік професор
Йоахім Зауер вирішили не переїжджати.
У розпорядженні канцлерки цілодобово автомобіль з шофером.
Тоді як багато німецьких посадовців віддають
перевагу броньованим Mercedes або BMW,
Анґела Меркель обирає Audi A8.
Літає канцлерка на лайнері Аirbus А340
- на дальні відстані та на Global 5000 - на середні.
Під час відпустки Анґела Меркель полюбляє ходити
у походи в гори з чоловіком.
За відпочинок канцлерка платить з власної кишені.
Час від часу навідується на свою дачу поблизу Берліна.
Ані яхт, ані розкішних палаців для відпочинку
у Меркель немає.